estamos aquí en rosiña la mayor Favela
de Río de Janeiro donde los selectores
ya están ejerciendo su derecho a voto
Aquí la gente está votando en función de
lo que creen mejor para el país para sus
familias y para el futuro de todos en
general
y la razón por la que voté por él es
porque él es del pueblo brasileño y creo
que los más necesitados van a tener una
mejoría con él
votando duda
voy a votar por luna por el clima de
violencia que tenemos asentado aquí en
nuestro país Acabo de ver el vídeo de
una diputada federal Armada persiguiendo
a un ciudadano negro creo que estamos en
un país racista y con prejuicios
están un clima un país
nuestro deber el del pueblo brasileño es
votar esperando siempre lo mejor para
nuestras familias para nuestro futuro
independientemente de quien vaya a
gobernar
aquí la mayoría de personas han
asegurado que van a votar por Lula Y es
que a pesar de que Río de Janeiro es una
zona fuertemente bolsonarista el petista
ha conseguido retomar los votos en las
zonas más pobres de la ciudad tras
cuatro años de gobierno de bolso no
obstante esta Favela Sigue estando
fuertemente dividida entre los apoyos a
bolsonaro y los apoyos a Lula aparte de
eso se espera que la jornada electoral
transcurra con normalidad hasta su
finalización hasta su finalización a las
17 horas de Brasilia